Super Bowl is this Sunday as you know  big deal Super Bowl and of course a big  part of the game is also the commercials  that air during the broadcast people  love watching those commercials one  thing I've noticed you probably notice  this too is that every year a company  puts out a sappy ad that is just solely  designed to tug at your heartstrings and  that's it they don't really talk about  the product they just tug at your  heartstrings you can't even tell what  they're selling half the time you'll see  what I mean check out this ad that's  gonna air this Sunday I wish dad was  here sweetie  special delivery you know someone else  wants to say hi - nope  good news Emily the disease you have we  cured it but that's not the only thing I  came to say Karen  marry me  Doritos now  and blasted cheddar  [Applause]